i want to ask you
does this not result naturally as the
evolutionary culmination
of the what i call the academic hunger
games i mean you start off and
get into the best college you need to do
all sorts of activities and get good
grades and take good
tests and and so forth then you go to
college and you're competing
in the physical sciences let's say
you're going to be a theoretical
physicist
you're competing with some of the
brightest minds who have ever lived in
your peer group
you've got to outlast them to get a good
good phd slot then you gotta
shine as a phd student get the attention
of your advisor
then you gotta get a good letter
recommendation and a job offer a
prestigious postdoc
then you gotta get a go it's just a mind
night it's gotten so much worse since
20 years ago when i went through the the
final rung in this laptop
and then yeah go ahead we have to stop
this
this is how do you stop it how do you
how do you undo a thousand-year-old uh
tradition this is not a
thousand-year-old tradition this has to
do with vannevar bush the endless
frontier the expansion of the
post-secondary education
system you know i was think i was
hanging out with the provost at the
ucsd and he didn't even understand the
effect of the isleberg amendment of 1976
by dole in 1980 the
fraudulent nsf and nas
projections of the looming shortage that
opened the floodgates uh
foreign labor universities that's
misclassification is student
apprenticeship
there's an entire recent horrible
history
of turning the modern professor
into a surf not just the graduate
student into a cert
but attempt to destroy academic freedom
if you cannot tell people to screw off
and know that you are still
funded the next day and you can still
come into your office
the field is lost
you